[Music]
an nypd captain was able to identify 15
teens connected to a deadly shooting
okay and now this one identified every
single one of them they're like [ __ ] the
teens it might not even be it's not that
necessarily like these are all the teams
that uh
that were
accomplishes but these are just people
that were connected to the crime that it
so it's like one dude was a driver one
dude was the shooter one dude saw it
because he was sitting on the bench
five kids were playing basketball but he
knew them
maybe they're teammates too they all
just took a selfie right after the event
yeah there's a team photo uh but yeah
he's identified 15 of them that were
connected to shooting and now he's
paying them 150 bucks each to attend a
healing circle
as a method to deter them from a life of
crime 150 ease for healing circle okay
what goes in the healing circle they sit
down sound bath
is that what that [ __ ] that [ __ ] oh they
do the [ __ ] bowl right
wow wow pretty sure that ain't it those
are like 25 bucks is there ayahuasca
involved could be you probably do like a
prayer or meditation ceremony but it's
like in new york so the bull goes hey yo
i'm walking here
i'm walking here i'm healing here
that's not real [ __ ] pizza
you call that a [ __ ] bagel
i'm italian
so the boys meet up each week for a
discussion led by a therapist at a local
community center hmm
yeah that's kind of cool
why do you have to pay him to do that
[ __ ] cause he make them all or you just
go i'ma throw your ass in jail
[ __ ] that's not enough captain
derby saint forte the commanding officer
of the 61st precinct was inspired by a
shooting that killed 17 year old devonta
his name is
oh is it because they're um these 15
kids are not
what do you call it they're not um being
indicted or they're
they're they're not they didn't commit a
crime he's trying to save them from
committing more crime so they were just
connected to it maybe they're not the
actual yeah
it's like a thing where i'm sure like if
you're uh the nypd captain in brooklyn
you probably know what path are headed
down because of their affiliations
so he's trying to save them from what
you know would be statistically i can't
wait to see a former reformed gangster
talk about how yoga saved their life
that'd be good that would be sick
because i'm sick of the pastors already
there's too many former gangster pastors
we don't need any more let's go down
this let's go to other spiritual realms
what else besides you never know because
even convicts
can have a heart of gold like you guys
remember the part in the dark night when
devo throws away the device yeah that
was going to blow up the other ferry
yeah i didn't see that coming i was like
this guy's about to blow up the whole
[ __ ] fairy so i thought too and he's
like nope and then change the heart and
then chris chris nolan moated me he's
like see
you're wrong
he did look super sinister too yeah he
threw it out the window he sat down and
everyone was scared to do anything dope
what a good guy yeah so like here here's
something in contrast so like obviously
when i read that i was like what the
[ __ ]
is that really gonna help
uh i just imagine something like that
being done with some people out here and
i'm like there's no [ __ ] way that'll
do anything but uh how do you know you
never tried interpretive dance to heal
the soul see yeah but i i'm a dancer i
never stopped to kill it you know what
the teens do i think the teens need to
actually like
do something they like because when i
was getting hella trouble my mom would
take me to [ __ ] temples and she would
try to do her own exorcisms on me and
[ __ ] a light incense and walk around me
for 30 minutes every single night trying
to get all the demons out of me none of
that [ __ ] [ __ ] worked if she
would just let me play my drums or let
me do my kung fu's i think i wouldn't
have stayed out of trouble what about
talking to a therapist
with the 15 to your family that's not
more fun than drugs that shit's not
gonna work cause i went so i had anger
management uh i have to say anger
management counselor every thursday
night did you like them because your mom
huh no the my school made me if i wanted
to stay at that school so i'm gonna kick
me out but i have to go with my mom
and uh that she doesn't help at all
because your mom needed anger management
because she beat you after are you sure
it doesn't help because like you're fine
now yeah
maybe it helps it was the ecstasy taught
me how to love okay so we give these
gangsters ecstasy
yeah and some it's a fix of people they
need to channel
it into something fun something exciting
because it has to be equivalent right if
you're [ __ ] out here
selling drugs you have freedom you're a
15 year old kid you could do whatever
the [ __ ] you want right
what is the equivalent what is going to
balance that to me
riding horses in the wilderness oh free
but that hurts your balls
you haven't thought about that right all
right all right snowboarding both legs
on the same side like a chick oh
why do you say chase can't ride at
normal no a rose did in titanic no they
can't because they'll start coming
okay yeah that's the best thing
speaking of derby so here's a here's a
little comparison right here um if
you're thinking like what the [ __ ] 150
dollars just to attend this thing um
that's one-tenth of the cost of keeping
someone in prison for a day wow so they
they see it as it's 1500 a day we don't
care about prison costs though when we
kill people
who are on death row like how long did
it take and how much money was that i
mean give me a break and this money is
not it's not police funding it's not the
money's not uh from taxpayers or
anything
it's evidence money oh it's evidence
money they're reusing it that's pretty
cool is it out of his pocket it's from
uh community donations oh please did the
police have a lemonade stand that means
they pulled you over and you had yeah
they had a bake sale they had a bake
sale using [ __ ] evidence cocaine
civil forfeiture yeah so they uh we
build the block executive director dana
ratchelin who runs the campaign behind
the circle said it costs 30 000
for 16 weeks of meetings all funded by
private donations
and it's been four months since the
group therapy sessions began and none of
the 15 boys have been arrested see
that's awesome told you it worked bro
it's just one month is it though for now
is it one more good for one month it's
just because this generation is [ __ ]
[ __ ]
that's why that's why you everyone needs
therapy if it was our era these fools
would have just jumped the therapist
it's robbed his ass yeah but these guys
are soft now i know so uh yeah so as i'm
reading this whose side are you on
you get lower in this article you start
going like oh so then i get to this part
where um yeah so then i mean that this
of course if someone say hey it's been
four months no one's been arrested that
doesn't honestly impress me because i'm
[ __ ] never arrested so but four
months
they need to [ __ ] wait a year so i'm
saying like i don't feel like it's a
long time but i guess in that community
you're impressed by it they would have
all been arrested four months is a long
time though that's pretty cool if you're
already headed down that path you're
doing that kind of [ __ ] like maybe every
day every week what changed you
and to turn from a life of crime
for me it was selling drugs
eternal weight from crime once again joe
i just don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about honestly though it makes
sense what he's saying is
when you're doing non-productive crime
selling drugs you actually start
building an entrepreneurial mindset
exactly and is weed illegal now thanks
for translating it might sound like you
down this road of actually doing less
risk adverse behavior yeah so instead of
fighting someone right because then
it'll jeopardize your business yeah now
you're fighting someone because they
didn't pay you for the [ __ ] dub sack
that they borrowed or you hire out so
instead of fighting somebody you host
the fight yeah you host the fight
you sent invoices for the drugs you sold
that's hella smart all right so uh
criminals substitute drugs with like
pokemon cards and be totally fine but i
see what you're trying to say they're
not that lucrative it's always about
what they're trying to say and you don't
get [ __ ] the way you do if you sell
drugs yeah that's true since uh this
program got out there uh criminologists
are like now kind of criticizing it and
they're saying that well further study
is needed to see if the program can be
replicated there's a quote from uh
professor
john from john jay college in manhattan
since he's from new york i gotta read it
like hey he goes someone's carrying a
gun they've already said whatever i
could do my five years upstate
[Laughter]
and you're saying he's 150 bucks is that
going to change things no oh my god
no
and and he's and they're also pointing
out that the teens that have gone to the
sessions are still being getting in
trouble with a lot two teenagers who
briefly visited the circle were arrested
last week in connection with a shooting
at a mall
so it's like
is it working or they didn't do it dude
they were just there yeah
everybody's at the mall yeah people love
them all if my mom was [ __ ] watching
though i'd be connected yeah she's like
and you're paying them guys suck at me i
want to see some nyc crime stats these
these are like so this is a year apart
everything that's red
that's gone up so uh felony assault is
up 11.5 murder is down good 18.8
shooting victims are up 31.6 rafe is up
26.5 jesus robbery is up 32.9 overall
crimes up 37 is it because they defunded
the police no it couldn't be that oh no
no no never mind that's because they uh
you know they funded criminals too much
they didn't defund the the police okay
but yeah that's that's why uh the cool
thing is this nypd captain is really
trying to come up with some kind of way
to uh make this a positive thing for the
community i
am more in the boat of i think that's
pretty cool until it proves like it
absolutely didn't work exactly yeah like
it sounds really great in theory and
it's got to do something it's facebook i
just think that this is so much hard
work you don't have to do this much work
all you do is turn them into gamers dude
turn them into [ __ ] gamers i swear to
god my little brothers found video games
i never saw him again
it's crazy and it's cheaper because you
just gave him a sick console and then
like you you'd be like yo he's here's a
[ __ ] streamy account
yeah what was it called the stream yard
stream though that's it
and what's my brother doing i don't know
he's playing a [ __ ]
game where he's delivering mail in the
futuristic dystopian future and i'm like
i don't know what those just get them
all in the metaverse and let them commit
crimes there yeah get it out of your
system in the metaverse you see that
game before the guy who did metal gear
oh yeah you have a mailman game yeah you
walk around and deliver packages holding
a big pack pack or whatever the [ __ ]
delivering post-apocalyptic time yeah
those simulators are very mundane things
are pretty typical so mundane that's
enough to keep you from a murder
tournament gamers the [ __ ] easiest
thing ever people just suck at
convincing other people to do better
[ __ ] if i was there if i was there
easily all the whole crime in the
neighborhood would be out i think it's
pretty great that they're getting these
guys in the room that's like the main
thing because at that in a moment like
that that's when you can really tell
them or at least focus them on something
they might be really good at that's the
key i think does it get people good at
[ __ ] it's too much uh
personal choice i don't like that i
think we should
create a a tunnel in brooklyn like a you
know like a [ __ ] manhole right like
the sewer hole
light it on fire right and just be like
you go to [ __ ] hell right now if you
come in another crime i'll kick you in
there like 300 kick you in a stomach
[ __ ]
into a manhole check this out got this
apartment for you this apartment has a
computer has all the video games that
you want also
you see this phone right here
we're gonna pay for the next six months
of postmates you can eat whatever the
[ __ ] you want dog this just feels like
another version of jen the book of
genesis yeah and it's like take your
pick this is how the mafia makes deals
right they go here's a great [ __ ]
deal it's either that or i'm gonna kill
you yeah okay
of course take the deal yeah i would
take the deal
i'm not gonna get kicked in the stomach
and fall into a fiery manhole
i gotta play [ __ ] diabolo three for
six months yeah man bart quan's gonna
order all the postmates for me oh man
you're golden without postmates
unlimited yeah he doesn't know about
that yet well then okay so like uh all
the um ideas combined like if i re i
really believe that a lot of people
don't know they're good at [ __ ] because
they're too busy doing stupid [ __ ]
that's what i think you got to help
people find what they do you help
somebody figure out what they're like or
if you're just the only person in life
that tells them you're really [ __ ]
good at this and they chase it what
happens to the people who aren't good at
anything everyone's good at something
you have to find it you'll find it yeah
some people are really good at opening
doors
so they could just stand by walmart open
the [ __ ] out of that door i'm pretty
good at opening doors i was an automatic
doorway you want to be the door opening
guy out of 15 kids in a healing circle i
could keep it up that's what the game
overcooked is for yeah people don't know
how to [ __ ] to do anything overcooked
pisses me off
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you